chiusura tout le monde così c'è il
giappone aspetta se avete noi toniste
chiude con oa tarassi video e yoko so
proprio quello oggi ragazzi ho provato
ho voluto fare questa cosa perché ho
nostalgia di quel dell'ultimo viaggio
che ho fatto in giappone con gianandrea
volevo provare a fare jazz tentando di
indovinare le varie location del
giappone no se riesco a capire dove mi
trovo sono stati giappone 3 volte tutte
e tre le volte ci sono stato tre
settimane l'una quindi totale ho fatto
tipo 2 mesi la quindi spero iddio di
poter riconoscere qualche strada visto
che sono stato più lì che a torino negli
ultimi anni proviamoci perfetto
magari non mettete mele a caso perché
come faccio a saperlo
magari magari posti famosi non proprio
quelli che ne so magari viventi
meccanismi in piedi semi pianti mezzo ad
abbiategrasso non è che però dove che
sia beh allora che la questa bella ecco
la cosa bellissima del giappone che non
possiamo mai capire dove siamo perché
come faccio genio di lille esso leggere
i canti che cos'è questo qua è siciliano
ragazzi kuzui vuol dire chi minchia
non è vero però più o meno ho trovato
roba qua allora va di velo subito si
capisce una sega o se hero se giro il
gioco del mister dritto andiamo a 6 kg a
destra mi ama shibata che non ho idea di
dove ma non era la più pallida idea
proprio nigata shiba eccola nigata
incredibile ho trovato nigata quindi
dovremo essere nel mezzo tra licata e
shibata che dovrebbe essere 32 32 anni
32 eccolo incredibile shibata sta qua
nigata sta qua quindi noi staremo e se
glielo come fa a essere 200 maledizione
che so saremmo qua nel mezzo preciso
trascinata a nigata
è una cagata otto ragazzi c'è tutto il
giappone c'era e non vorrei di 12
chilometri è un signor risultato c'è
neanche ma neanche a catanzaro risaputo
posizionarmi meglio quindi va bene
davanti bellissimo siamo vicino al monte
fuji non lo so so sparare vola e la zona
chiaramente di montagna lo intravedo da
dalle montagne sembrava un po la
location di del training prove la
madonnina frate porca vacca non è
neanche giapponese queste richard gere
madonna che macchina fratello mio
complimenti ti piace alle macchine
giapponesi perché sembra tutte finte sto
cabin ottino che va col volante
bellissimo e ero lì ed era un ottimo
punto per capire dove eravamo ma non
riesco più ad arrivarci quindi niente
risalire le scale sono chilometri che
devo fare per rimettermi nella strada
ottimo ma questa con grazia e la grove
street giapponese secondo me siamo più o
meno v qui dottore cornelius funk art of
effettura di motore ok
mettiamoci dato core perché sono
convinto che sarà lei perfetto a perché
il giappone anche questa parte va bene
questo caldo va bene ragazzi allora next
bellissimo voglio questo a casa ora
perfetto se prima ero finito nel nulla
adesso ancora peggio spiega raggiungiamo
questi salve ma tobago non lo so ma non
so dai partiti che ne so
fukushima nel mezzo del nulla allora è
comunque tutti sperduti nel nulla mi
amerà ficcati e porca vacca pensa questi
mi sarà godono qua
ragazzi è successo e succede
quanta probabilità avevo di schiacciare
a caso in tutto il giappone e di beccare
a 4 km e 8 come no non ci credo ci posso
credere non ci posso credere che questa
cosa ma devo salvare questa parte sta
parte del video raga salvatela perché è
leggendaria cioè io schiacciato a caso
accesso completamente un peccato 4 km
boh avevo invitato incredibile medici
qui c'è che almeno ora era scopro dritto
rispetto al processore sia azzeccato il
punto della stessa incredibile
incredibile
non so cosa dire giuro che culo ai
ragazzi proviamo a fare da okinawa ad
osaka le e giappone quindi questa gara
non ci sono stato sia okinawa osaka
metti ma porca vacca perché quello di
prima era troppo di fitch e ti puntava
in mezzo alla sala il nulla quindi
l'unico modo che avevi era di
schiacciare nel mezzo della mappa e
sperare di beccarlo il punto però c'è
una possibilità su un milione
non mi poteva mai succedere e invece
proviamo invece a vedere i luoghi c'è
spero sia più easy ecco come non detto
ma ci ha scritto che era facile porca
vacca due mesi kato e vabbè prima invece
era andare sulle città mira temi da
questo punto i tokyo 250 location a
tokyo va bene tokyo ragazzi e ci sono
stato della città dove ci sono state le
sono state ovviamente di più chi li
vediamo vediamo
va bene ho capito che il pallonetto
ragazzi tokyo è grossa ok se fai una
triangolazione aosta milano torino
quel l'area che ci sta nel mezzo della
grandezza di tokyo quindi è grossa non
puoi farmi mettermi in un punto a caso
ok non potrò mai azzeccare così quindi
dammi ho visto gli eventi sono stupido
io ho visto lì e benji non lo so
mettiamo qui direte conto prima come ho
fatto ad azzeccare nel punto a caso del
giappone che ma che siamo nella stessa
città sono otto chilometri di rete conto
di quanto culo ho avuto prima
ma cosa succede qua mi scusi cos'è che
porta o peccato perché ha dei guanti da
forno per tenere la bici
vabbè non ho capito andiamo avanti siamo
nel nulla come sempre prove giacca
tocchi gigantesca raramente i posti
famosi ma come faccio parco demonio 9 kg
c'è veramente non riuscirò mai a fare
meno di 4 km e l'ho fatto a caso va bene
ti chiedo un becco un posto che
conoscono già farò mai e ve lo dico ma
ce ne sono un sacco di parchi così ne ho
visti il sacco quindi non ha senso lato
questa andata fa foto dove c'era il
parco precisamente ok va bene ragazzi
visto che con il giappone non c'è verso
proviamo delle se a milano
milano ci azzecco da è difficile ok a
casa mia questa buongiorno da tokyo a
milano va bene ok allora vediamo se
riesco a parlare con decente non ho idea
di dove potremmo essere
male anche a milano porca vacca e tu e
geo localizzati a tokyo maledizione dove
siamo qua non ho la più pallida idea
almeno un po sa.va almeno milano almeno
milan ora che a popolarità saremo sul
forlan
sparandoci non lo sa neanche dove
forlani sparo centrali maggiolina ok era
più vicino a tokyo 4 km e 7 alla
famosissima via larga qualcuno ci
abitava sicuro di quelli che stanno al
nostro video scusatemi ragazzi non ho
idea di dove possa essere quarto cagnino
se ho capito ma mi devi buttare a milano
milano non fuori ma porca vacca aspetto
che le cose fatte bene ho finalmente la
via che conosco
conosco niente fondazione per la meglio
a ok so dove la fondazione anche io sì
sì sì sì sì sì sì
quora tipo qua sotto ecco la mappa per
ora tutto qua tutto qui eravamo tipo qui
più o meno
beh un chilometro cioè vi rendete conto
che sapendo dove a milano di preciso
sono andato quasi vicino come
geolocalizzabili a caso il tutto il
giappone c'è com'è possibile
buongiorno salve posso chiederti
esattamente cosa stai mettendo nella
macchina c'è cos'è un poco piazza lodi
piazza lodi rocco siffredi presenta
lasciati sedurre molto bene corso lodi
che si trova che corso lodi non lo so
non lo so dove corso lodi lega non lo so
maledizione vabbè mi devo schiacciato a
casola che impossibile veramente io non
ci credo che non riesco neanche ad
azzeccare a mila a milan e che di cibo
ma una via che una via una una via che
una sola neanche una volta che dico è
qua almeno una o demoni questa passiamo
in giappone
però i treni tre di queste centrale
centrale questa peccato celo celo questa
centrale fermi tutti allora ci sono le
scale mobili quindi sarà qui
porco demonio stati da una parte un po
vedi che sono stupito dai ragazzi or
capi ormai abbiamo finito tutto il gioco
si è stancato di farvi vedere che non so
dove sono quindi va beh sembra vi sia
piaciuto è stato molto difficile farlo
perché tra tokyo e milano due città dove
ho vissuto non so riconoscere una sega
quindi non saprei neanche geolocalizza
mia casa mia
lasciamo perdere peso tuo commento mi
piace ti è piaciuto di sky canale
schiacciate con la bellissima
campanellina e vedete vicino a il tasto
iscritti che mi serve per vedere le
notifiche quando pubblico i video sono
pericolosi come sempre ci vediamo a un
prossimo video della ragazzi
[Musica]